you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with anemia as a result
of chronic kidney disease or ckd
this video will help you understand some
of the available treatment options for
ckd anemia
anemia means your blood does not have
enough healthy red blood cells to
deliver oxygen to the body
anemia can result from chronic kidney
disease
normally the kidneys make a hormone
called erythropoietin
this hormone helps bone marrow make new
red blood cells when the kidneys are
damaged they don't make enough of this
hormone
as a result bone marrow doesn't make
enough red blood cells causing ckd
anemia
this means that organs and tissues may
not work as well as they should
treatment options for ckd anemia may
include one or more of the following
an erythropoietin stimulating agent
iron and a blood transfusion
an erythropoietin stimulating agent or
esa
helps your bone marrow make new red
blood cells
another treatment option is iron
your doctor may prescribe oral iron this
means pills taken by mouth
or you may receive intravenous iron
therapy
in this procedure iron is delivered
through an iv to increase the amount of
iron in your blood
for severe anemia you may need a blood
transfusion
this means you will be given red blood
cells and iron through an iv
it will quickly increase the amount of
these substances in your blood
if you have questions about treatments
for ckd anemia or any medications you
have been prescribed talk to your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed and report any side effects
you have
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you